mire
[Aplausos]
esperando reavivar las históricas
marchas que llenaron las calles de la
habana el verano pasado la oposición
cubana convocó este lunes una marcha
cívica por el cambio exige la liberación
de más de 650 presos políticos
encarcelados desde las protestas del 11
de julio sin embargo la marcha fue
declarada ilegal por el gobierno que
alega que eeuu está detrás de la
iniciativa y condenado como ustedes
mismos se convocaron las campañas por
subvertir el orden interno las campañas
mediáticas contra cuba contra la paz de
cuba y contra el bloqueo y cubaba a
vivir en paz y viviendo en bajo vamos a
perfeccionar mano a mano el domingo las
fuerzas de seguridad intensificaron la
presión rodeando la casa de un destacado
disidente e impulsor de la marcha del
15m júnior garcía aguilera mi caso
amaneció 7a
está rodeado todo el edificio de agentes
de la seguridad del estado vestidos de
civil haciéndose pasar por pueblos como
suelen hacer eso no sorprende a ningún
cubano al menos otros seis líderes de
archipiélago el grupo de protesta creado
por júnior garcía fueron igualmente
impedidos de salir de sus casas este
domingo eeuu condenó las tácticas de
intimidación de la habana hacemos un
llamado al gobierno cubano para que
respete los derechos de los cubanos
permitiéndoles reunirse pacíficamente
hacer uso de sus voces sin temor a
represalias o violencia por parte del
gobierno y manteniendo abiertas las
líneas de internet y de
telecomunicaciones
anteriormente las autoridades cubanas
revocaron las credenciales de seis
periodistas de la agencia de noticias
española efe antes de restituir las
únicamente a dos de los periodistas del
equipo